is there another creature that might
stand a chance against
[Music]
so first of all Godzilla is a story that
we sort of all grew up with what is it
like to continue this story and bring it
to an audience it's an honor it's
amazing honor yes yes fan honor to be
part of that legacy is crazy amazing one
of the things that we know about this
movie cast was that you're a prankster
oh yes and so can we talk about some of
the pranks that you pulled on set and
how much planning pre-planning it's
definitely premeditated I actually never
prank you never cuz I was I was honestly
quite frightened I just didn't know what
like what wouldn't happen then it would
start a war with him and I just didn't
think that that was smart
yeah but there it's fun kids you know
because I'm a motor I'm in a motor so if
I get pranked oh my mode yes i stoic he
plays unprintable
no no no he won't go right until until
Godzilla stomps it to theaters this may
take
Billy this is your film debut what does
it feel like to jump over to movie
stardom do you feel different so I feel
different no I don't but I I it's an
extreme on a part of a legacy especially
you know Godzilla is one of the biggest
stars of Hollywood and to be part of a
movie that's a you know franchise and
not only that with some of my favorite
actors mostly these two here the other
ones are okay I just did pressured them
for like two hours some like cut away
fun experience did you take any advice
or learn anything from them on set and
did you guys feel like you had to sort
of like to wrap your pretending we were
taking it I learned from her yeah she
tell us what to do she was one who came
up the idea of like she's I need music I
need music play music and so Michael
Dougherty would like curate the most
beautiful music to him to put us into
gear yeah I love her right and it's a
collaboration I learned a lot from them
and they don't really have to speak so I
like I would just watch them and even if
I wasn't in the shots I'd watch of watch
the monitoring and I'd take it all in
because it's like one of my favorite
things to do is when I'm not on screen
watch the screen and I'd learn a lot so
like every project I'm doing right now
like in my teen years it's like it's
important because it's a life experience
and I'm learning new things just about
me as a person but I'm so sorry to sound
but but what sue me as a character so it
definitely helped a lot okay couple
things coming up in Hollywood veera
we're very excited for when they see us
tell me is there any money we need is
from one to tie this whole thing
together
ava duvernay is operating at the next
level of filmmaking it is a very
powerful piece this is a chance for the
Central Park five who would we'd never
even knew their names now it's their
story told and emotional for you I play
a Lizabeth letter who was the
prosecuting attorney assigned to the
case
like even magic she's boss the Queen
she's just a beautiful human being
ordained to do what she does here joy
being on herself
yeah ordained is such a good worthy of
that milieu recently revealed that Game
of Thrones you auditioned and didn't get
the part I want to know some things are
you still a fan can you still watch is
what you're still coming would you do
the prequel what I have like no idea
what what Game of Thrones even is like I
heard of it so many times but never
actually like watched it fully through I
don't know if winter is coming or not
it's summer is coming I don't know what
month it is but I think summer is coming
next and and do I want to be in the
prequel probably not because I ought to
come aloud because I have a lot of other
things going I am very very busy we're
excited about the new season of stranger
things what can you tell us we're not
kids anymore
I mean what did you think
we're just gonna sit my basement all day
we gave you the rest of our lives 11
character evolves greatly and I can say
it's spreading fast and that's all I can
tell you I love that okay last question
is for you Kyle
my favorite show of all time Tyler in my
house let me tell you something else
there's no talking back on the field I
mean it's everything it's everything
have you seen it has I seen it
I brought much success oh the so excite
every so see ya okay so here's the
question when you were on Friday Night
Lights did you know that Michael B
Jordan would become such a smoke show
you like winning games Vince yes sir
me too maybe give you a chance to the
ball someone other than him smoke show
Michael B Jordan was so young I mean you
know that he would be successful in beer
the young star like Michael B Jordan
smoke dissipates he's not dissipating
you know I think it's pretty easy to say
that yeah he was you knew he was a good
guy when you met him he was young he was
starting out and he's just good people
and he's very talented so it doesn't
surprise me one bit
it really does it yeah no it really
doesn't I would like you guys to make
more of that show by the way I know you
can't but I would like it right we would
like it I have a Tammy Taylor sizer
totally be down to play your door oh you
know it there's a new marriage okay I
see where Bang Bang going like I've got
this there's like a new marriage like
Tammy's not there anymore Tammy's what
are you having husband it
no Tammy was his daughter you taking a
new child I'm British I'm gonna clean it
you